what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are picking up with flash War
part 2 okay flash war part 2 is amazed
you do okay do flashes on me I really
wish Joshua blame should have been in
Denver Comic Con because I got to see
everybody else I gotta see him - Sam
Humphries and hang out with him do you
have mad love state Humphries ready he's
like what am i one of my top 5 favorite
writers like I'll read anything that guy
writes but uh but anyway okay so flash
war is basically kind of like wrapping
up the whole thing with Wally West right
like we talked about that in the first
video that in DC Universe rebirth number
one Barry Allen had essentially pulled
Wally West out of the Speed Force and
then Wally's just kind of been
free-floating ever since like he's been
in a couple flash stories he's been on
the been part of the main Titans roster
but that's really it like the whole idea
of like what's going on with him behind
the scenes and how it ties into all the
different aspects of the flash mythos
that had basically been missing
throughout all this time none of those
questions were really answered and flash
war gives us this specifically this
story opens up with Jai and Iraq I
always thought it was iris West and I
feel like it was iris West at one point
and then it was changed and I want to
say somebody mentioned that it did for
comic-con that it was iris West before
before Jeff Jones wrote Infinite Crisis
and then it was I Rea afterwards
although I'm not gonna swear to that the
cool thing about this is remember when
it came to joy or when it came to the
kids of Wally West a lot of lessons he
imparted on them were part and parcel to
you what happened with impulse with Bart
Allen and the reason why was because
after Barry Allen died in crisis on
Infinite Earths released was believed to
have been dead Wally West became the new
flash and the idea of DC at the time was
well let's just give him a new kid flash
like it makes the most sense so they
grabbed Bart Allen from the future they
said that his Speed Force powers were
running out of control he didn't really
know how to contain them and so they
brought him to the 20th century they
handed him over to Wally teach him how
to control his powers Wally didn't know
how he was like I mean I guess I can but
I'm not really a teacher I can impart
what pearls of wisdom I gained from
Barry but I'm not really a teacher less
regard I'm not that familiar with the
Speed Force and now those things change
with stories like terminal velocity but
what did up happening was Bart Allen was
handed over to a to max mercury who
trained him but the idea of Wally
helping the kind of get impulses powers
and check which is to say putting him in
a position to where his his Speed Force
abilities are stabilized and they're not
accelerating his aging is basically what
was imparted to to to the kids of Wally
it was sitting down and saying they had
the exact same problem that's kind of
where this comes from the issue with
this is that Wally didn't remember him
when while he came back he did not
remember his kids and that's kind of the
crazy thing is that it was a it was a
little piecemeal now
in reality I'd say this is Joshua
Williamson kind of going through and
doing it in stages right like if Wally
had come back in DC universe rebirth
number one and then it turned into where
Wally West kids and it turns like the
whole thing was Linda Park then like
basically the whole concept of Wally
would have been flushed out into six
months and there would have been no real
storytelling to give after that instead
what DC is doing here is they're staging
it out they're saying here's Wally when
he comes back and then here's a couple
things here and there and then here's
Wally whistlin part of his past and
there's a couple things here and there
and then here's flash war we basically
have a whole kit and caboodle and so
it's cool for what it is because what we
end up knowing here at least what we're
kind of told here is that a lot of this
centers around hunter zolomon I remember
in the last video we talked about this
that hunter zolomon was geoff johns
reverse-flash the thing here is that
what you end up having is you end up
having Wally who kind of freaks out and
attacks attacks hunter zolomon and when
he does he starts to get these kind of
flashback of memories in the sense that
he almost kind of absorbs memories
directly from hunter zolomon himself now
this is part and parcel to the powers of
Wally West so back when Wally really
became the flash replaced Barry the idea
was to make him different the idea of
Wally is to say okay let's make him
interesting and unique and so Wally has
powers and has abilities that are tied
to him that no one else has for example
Wally West cannot be cut off from the
Speed Force this is the reason why when
DC we birth happened Wally West was
absorbed into the Speed Force as opposed
to just kind of losing his powers and
just sort of being a regular person out
there somewhere Wally main lines it and
so because of that fact like he's wildly
powerful not only that when it comes to
like time travel Barry Allen has to use
a cosmic treadmill he can bounce through
dimensions he can like you know vibrate
himself from one dimension to the next
but he can't run back and forward
through time of his own volition he has
to use a cosmic treadmill to do it Wally
does not have that limitation he can run
back and forth through time and will
actually we'll see how that kind of
plays out here but one of the other big
things that Wally has and this is I
believe a power that was actually given
to people after Wally is he has the
ability to kind of transfer Speed Force
powers to people that have given like
healing factors different things like
that but when he basically goes to
attack hunter zolomon because this
ability that he has he picks up on the
realization that hunter doesn't have his
powers anymore and this is kind of the
cool thing is because the way Williamson
writes this it's a bit of a mystery here
we kind of know that hunter zolomon is
working with eobard thawne but we don't
know how far this goes and where hunter
zolomon is talking to Wally what he's
doing is saying things like my powers
are gone I don't have
anymore because of the fact that my
powers are gone it's given me time they
kind of reflect on my life to reflect
the decisions that I made and the things
that I've done and ultimately I've
essentially seen the light hunter
zolomon was originally a good guy he
fell to becoming a villain because he
was obsessed with the idea of fixing his
own past his desire to become a villain
was rooted in his own struggles and
strife the things that people go through
he just took a different road but
Redemption was always right around the
corner for Hunter and Wally doesn't
really know how to take that but at the
same time while he's also a good guy
he's like I mean we kind of have to give
him the benefit of the doubt but more so
than any of that hunter zolomon knows
the location or claims to know the
location of where Wally's kids are and
how to get them and so the overriding
factor here for Wally is he wants his
kids back and so it was kind of a
throwback for the old school Wally fans
all kinds of things go into this whole
ideology and so from here you really
kind of sidetrack for a second with with
Barry and with the Renegades now of
course the Renegades are kind of like
this temporal police force that have
been created by by hunter zolomon
himself but there was kind of a bigger
ruse that was going on we didn't really
know what it was all we knew was that
the idea was iris West was being taken
for the quote unquote murder of eobard
thawne and that was it what you ended up
picking up here with is this idea that
Barry's kind of like look I need to find
Wally West now this is kind of one of
those interesting situations where you
kind of see like Barry and Wally
juxtaposed next to each other and then
you kind of get you know really kind of
come you know be kind of it I guess come
to this understanding that the story is
what makes the characters interesting
right like Barry Allen in of himself is
not really interesting to me he's just a
guy who runs really fast flash war to me
is interesting because it's about Wally
getting his kids back that's it is it's
Wally going to every length he needs to
to get his kids back but it's Wally
reach right in the water of what Barry
Allen did Barry Allen's just kinda like
runny trying to find Wally avala like
where in the world is Wally West and you
know you guys have the Renegades have
been set up this is all just one great
big huge ruse you guys have been tricked
you don't know it but you guys have been
tricked you know Barry basically grabs
uh you know commander cold they whisk
over to where hunter zolomon is only for
us to find out that what's actually
going on is hunters all know was the one
pulling the strings that basically sent
like you know the the renegades after
iris West
knowing Wally would follow and with
Wally would come Barry now of course
with hunter zolomon kind of being
incapacitated at the moment and more or
less being defeated the whole conflict
switches to Barry versus Wallach and
this is where it really picks up and
this is why I say like like Joshua
Williams that I think is one of the most
prolific writers in recent years when it
comes to the flash because it's a way to
take these characters who other
may not necessarily have been
interesting and turn them into like
wildly interesting as much as I loved
Frances mana pools run at the end of the
day it all just kind of came down to
what we got to fight gorilla grodd in
gorilla City and new Irish and that kind
of a thing like like with this it's it's
wall-e legitimately on the hunt for his
kids and it's kind of cool because you
can look at this and you can say like I
understand exactly where Molly's coming
from if I had kids and then they
vanished one day I would go to the ends
of the earth I would set the world on
fire if it meant that I would get my
kids back I would sacrifice everyone I
would eliminate everything in my path do
whatever I needed to do in order to get
my kids back here and that's the whole
point is that where Berry's kind of sent
directly to Wally by virtue of commander
colt using the flash but I guess using
the Speed Force signature of Wally to
kind of create like a pinpoint more or
less where Barry can be sent to when he
finally catches up with him this turns
into like one somebody did something and
screwed up the timeline so everything
starts going nuts
it looks like the actions of dr.
Manhattan if I'm being honest with you
guys and - once Barry catches up to
Wally directly the two of them kind of
engaged this this incredible
conversation because Barry's kind of
trying to impart this this little bit of
wisdom right saying hey look take it
from me the guy who trained you you
can't do this kind of thing you can't
just like run around and do crazy
situations and doing these crazy events
because what you're gonna do if you run
back in time you don't know what you're
gonna change there's no such thing
really it's like alternate realities
doesn't really exist I mean the notion
of DC sitting down and saying like well
there's all these alternate realities of
stem out of a single action it doesn't
really work that way anymore flashpoint
kind of solidified that and a few things
in rebirth solidified that what this
mean is that if Wally goes back and
let's say it like he he goes into the
Speed Force he breaks it he goes in and
like rescues his kids no one knows what
the consequence will be that's the
importance of all this because that's
what Wally's doing while his idea is I
can run it to the Speed Force I'll crack
it a little bit but nothing really
terrible is gonna happen but it's like
breaking glass it's only a matter of
time before the whole thing shatters and
that's the whole point is because the
idea seems to be no one knows exactly
what will happen if this Speed Force
wall is what holds the multiverse
together and all does everything all the
universe is just kind of free float into
oblivion if the destruction of the Speed
Force means all the speedsters lose
their power no one knows what the
consequences of this will be but for
Wally it doesn't matter he doesn't care
what the aftermath of this will be he's
a dad who wants to find his kids and
it's kind of funny because when you have
Barry sitting down like Wally's idea is
look like you were a mentor once once
upon a time but I've been flash like I
was flash for a long time I've carved my
niche I know what I'm about but if
you're getting in my way of finding my
fighting my kids
you're no friend of mine so I'm gonna
give you a choice you can move out of
the way or I can run you over and that's
what's so cool this is kind of like
Redemption time for Wally West fans
because there's like this amazing
standoff you know Barry's like well if
you run I'll catch you and while he's
like you can try I can give you a head
start and you still wouldn't catch me
and that's true Wally is faster than
Barry and that's what's so awesome about
this is because like you can try your
best you could do anything you want to
do but at the end of the day if I take
off running in that direction I'll have
to stop in order for you to catch me
you're never gonna catch up and so
because that like it's it's it's awesome
here because Wally just like takes off
and it's kind of interesting the way
that it's drawn you almost see it right
you see like the look of Barry like
please Wally don't do it and while he's
like this is happening and Wally just
bolts he's just like gone and Barry
tries to chase after him and that's
where this ends but it's like it's like
erm like dude it's so good
like it's so amazing oh man I love flash
for so much it's so badass but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
comment explain make sure you guys have
the sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoy this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace